künstliche Muttermilch eine
revolutionäre Erfindung doch was steckt
eigentlich
[Musik]
drin so riecht das wenn ich das Bad
sauber gemacht habe aber original
Sebastian nimmt sich die künstliche
Babymilch zur Brust und lüftet das
Geheimnis des potenten Pulvers dabei
bekommt der ganz besonderen Support
Mutter künstliche Muttermilch was für
ein wahnsinnstrick der
Lebensmittelindustrie Kuhmilch im
Muttermilch
verwandeln da muss es drauf haben die
Auswahl ist riesig Sebastian lege schaut
sich an wie die Industrie ihre Babymilch
verkauft
organic na ja und für die nachhaltigen
pappdose und alles im Bio da wird auch
für jede Zielgruppe das passende Produkt
mal
rausgehauen und ganz wichtig auch
Supreme ist dabei ne wenn du möchtest
dass aus seinem Kind Superman oder
Wonder Woman wird dann fütterst du nur
Supreme da kommt gleich die Beule aus
dem Arm aber noch Pampers
an ich rufe mal meine Mutter an und frag
die was ich bekommen habe
Mutter
Mutter sag mal Mama ich drehe gerade ein
Film über Babymilch und ich wollte mal
fragen was hast du mir denn so gegeben
als Baby du biston
von Soler künstlich Milch überhaupt
nicht satt geworden wie ich bin von so
künstlicher Milch nicht satt geworden
vom Krankenhaus haben sie mir das
mitgegeben und dann habe ich das
versucht das ging überhaupt nicht und
dann habe ich haerflocken hier
Schmelzflocken genommen und halb Milch
halb Wasser und du warst fertig mit der
Welt du hast so schön geschlafen also du
hast harmig Wasser und Schmelzflocken
weil ich ja nicht satt geworden bin mama
ich liebe dich ich habe dich auch lieb
tschüss
die hat ihre eigene Mischung gemacht
Haarmilch Wasser
Schmelzflocken schon wurde der lege
gebaut der kleine erst ältere Babys
vertragen Kuhmilch allen anderen hilft
die
Spezialmilch laut Packung sie kann von
Geburt ang gegeben werden und soll sogar
Blähungen vermeiden ein viel
verersprechendes Industrieprodukt ich
würde sagen lege macht jetzt Babymilch
dafür braucht der Produktentwickler eine
Spezialmaschine das hier ist ein echter
laborsprühtrockner der Macht aus
flüssiger Kuhmilch Milchpulver die
Kuhmilch wird in dem Gerät fein verteilt
und stark erhitzt dabei verdampft das
enthaltene
Wasser 175 brauchen wir sind nur ein
paar Grad dann geht's los ah die Pumpe
es geht los da da da geht die Milch lang
hier hier
hier geil und da unten sammelt sich
schon gleich das
Pulver 6 bis 7 l Milch stecken in einem
Kilo
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Pulver das laut aus 2 l Milch haben wir
so viel Milchpulver Wahnsinn oder Milch
besteht a Wasser das haben wir jetzt
rausgeholt sie denken das
war's kommen sie
[Musik]
mit das hier sind alle Zutaten die wir
benötigen um aus sprühgetrockneter
Kuhmilch künstliche Muttermilch
herzustellen sie sehen richtig das sind
alle Zutaten die in so Produkt ten sind
na ja so ein Kalb sagt hey die kich
reicht mir aus aber für Menschenbaby
brauchen man die ganzen Zutaten die
Regularien sind streng mehr als 30
verschiedene Zusätze sind für Babymilch
per Verordnung vorgeschrieben die hat
Sebastian lege alle für seinen Nachbau
besorgt hier ist mein selbsergestelltes
Milchpulver damit geht's ja los ne
also Kette und Ballaststoffe Mineralien
und Eiweiße all das macht aus
kuhmilchpulver eine
Babymilch die erste rutschwer schon mal
getan jetzt kommen die nächsten Sachen
beim Trocknen sind einige Vitamine
zerstört worden sie werden industriell
hergestellt und nachträglich dem
milchpulber wieder
zugesetzt Bo was so Babys alles brauchen
ne Vitamin E die Industrie muss alles
beimischen was getrockneter Kuhmilch
fehlt außerdem soll Babymilch gut zu
lagern lange haltbar und leicht zu
verarbeiten sein jetzt kommt irgendwie
das krasseste
Kupfersulfat sieht eher aus wie
schlumpfpulver aber ist wirklich
Kupfersulfat so riecht das wenn ich das
Bad sauber gemacht habe aber original
Kupfersulfat ist giftig aber in
geringsten Mengen gesundheitlich
unbedenklich und gilt als wichtiger
Mineralstoff
Sebastian lege vermischt all die
trockenen
[Musik]
Zutaten und fertig ist das babymenü und
jetzt kommt das schönste an dieser
Sendung ich darf Babymilch
[Musik]
probieren ich freue mich das Pulver wird
mit heißem Wasser
angerührt
das schmeckt aber
fürchterlicher meine Mama hat mir vorin
ja noch erzählt ich mochte es gar nicht
also heute auch nicht meine Mutter hat
die Mischung selber gemacht und ich habe
früh genug was zwischen Kim bekommen Kön
sehen was raus geworden ist Babymilch
wird heute jeden Tag Millionen von Babys
rund um den Globus gefüttert dies
Erfindung der Lebensmittelindustrie hat
die Welt verändert Ende des 19
Jahrhunderts steckt Europa mitten in der
Industrialisierung Frauen arbeiten in
Fabriken haben keine Zeit mehr zum
Stillen Babys werden darum oft von amen
oder mit einer Mischung aus Wasser und
Getreide ernährt der Schweizer Chemiker
enri Nestle bringt zum ersten Mal
sogenanntes kindermehl auf den Markt
Babys vertragen es besser die
Kindersterblichkeit sinkt
noch mehr Frauen können und sollen
arbeiten gehen und kaufen
[Musik]
babymilchpulver für Nestle ist es ein
gigantischer wirtschaftlicher Erfolg die
Erfindung der Babymilch legt den
Grundstein für den heute größten
Lebensmittelhersteller der Welt dass es
standardisierte
qualitätsgesicherte Anfangsmilch gibt
ist ein Segen für all die Kinder deren
Mütter nicht stillen können oder wollen
oder vielleicht gar nicht da sind weil
sie verstorben sind auch diese Kinder
muss man ja ernähren insofern ist es gut
dass es industriell hergestellte
anfangsdarung gibt die den strengen
Regeln der EU unterworfen ist nach
zahlreichen Skandalen ist Babymilch
heute das am strengsten regulierte
Lebensmittel
überhaupt auf 29 Seiten ist von der EU
genau geregelt welche Stoffe Babymilch
enthalten muss auch die Mengen sind auf
das Gramm genau vor geschrieben alle
Hersteller müssen also Milchpulver mit
den gleichen vorgegebenen Inhaltsstoffen
anbieten beim Marketing suchen Sie
Lücken im Gesetz es gibt Produkte die
wärben damit dass sie besonders tolle
Inhaltsstoffe haben wie z.B
unverdauliche Kohlenhydrate oder auch
Mikroorganismen die dafür sorgen sollen
dass mein Kind gesund bleibt oder einen
gesunden Darm hat es gibt aber bis heute
kein wissenschaftlichen Nachweis darüber
dass diese Produkte wirklich besser sind
als herkömmliche säuglingsanf ung nur
beim Preis sind die Unterschiede
gewaltig nestley verlangt für seine
bbermilch dreimal so viel wie
Handelsmarken aus der
Drogerie dabei liegt der Unterschied vor
allem in der goldenen
Verpackung früh investiert Nestle in
Marketing bis in die 1980er Jahre hinein
bekommen junge Mütter häufig noch im
Krankenhaus von Ärzten und Pflegekräften
kostenlose Babymilch nach Hause
mitgegeben dabei setzt sich zu diesem
Zeitpunkt längst die Erkenntnis durch
dass gestillte Babys gesünder aufwachsen
seit dem Jahr 1990 gibt die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation die
eindeutige Empfehlung Neugeborene
sollten bis zum sechsten Lebensmonat
wenn möglich gestillt werden die
Muttermilch ist besser zuowohl für das
Baby als auch für die Mutter für die
Mutter ist es von Vorteil wenn sie
stillt ihr brustkreb Risiko sinkt durch
Stillen und für das Kind ist es besser
weil die Milch hat Stoffe die man in der
industriell nicht herstellen kann also
sie ist auf alle Fälle besser als jede
industriell hergestellte Milch für
Nestle ein harter Schlag Regierungen
unterbinden außerdem aggressives
Marketing für
Babymilch in der aktuellen EU-Verordnung
heißt es werbung darf nicht implizieren
oder suggerieren dass Flaschennahrung
der Muttermilch gleichwertig oder
überlegen ist doch diese strengen Regeln
gelten längst nicht
überall außerhalb der EU darf Babymilch
als Chance für Mütter beworben
werden in Asien sucht Nestle neue
Abnehmer für sein Milchpulver der
Konzern vermarktet seine Produkte in
Vietnam gezielt auch für ältere
[Musik]
Kinder geht esch NLE sollen sogar vier
bis sejährige in Vietnam noch regelmäßig
Pulvermilch
trinken Schulkinder in Pakistan sollen
dank Milchpulver besser lernen können
verspricht die Werbung von
[Musik]
Nestle für Kindler die älter sind als 12
Monate ist es überhaupt nicht sinnvoll
spezielle Babyprodukte zu kaufen diese
Kinder sollen schon an der normalen
familienmahlzeit teilnehmen und dazu
gehört eben auch die normale Milch die
deutlich günstiger ist als diese
speziellen Kinderprodukte Babymilch ist
für Nestle ein Milliardengeschäft in
Ländern mit Lachsen Vorschriften wirbt
der Konzern mit Methoden die in Europa
aufgrund von wissenschaftlichen
Erkenntnissen längst verboten
sind